enjoy the journey enjoy the whole step
the whole process every day that you get
up to strive for whatever it is you're
after you can learn what's in you
sitting back and a lazy boy chair hit
the remote control watching HBO and
cinema intellect can describe it but
only instinct confounded you must
understand that the purpose is an
underlying of chemistry that makes you
live your life your kids are not going
to make you happy your spouse is not
going to make you happy a big house is
not going to make you happy we are
busier than any other generation we have
seen in the last three to four hundred
years if you don't know who you are
somebody can ascribe any identity on to
you and you were more friend or whatever
they want you to be if everything went
the way you wanted it to go you wouldn't
have anything to exercise by it's
because we are starting every day with
the burdens from yesterday assaulting us
in today I don't care whether you're 30
40 50 60 70 there's something down
inside of you the still kicking he's an
American pastor author and filmmaker
he's the Bishop of the potter's house a
non-denominational American mega church
he's received numerous honors including
13 honorary degrees and doctorates
he's bishop TD jakes and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success enjoy
the journey not the destination a lot of
us delay our happiness when I get to
this level when I get my degree when I
get the kids when I get married I'm
going to be happy enjoy the journey
enjoy the whole step the whole process
every day that you get up to strive for
whatever it is you're after you know I'm
a goal-oriented guy yeah so you don't
celebrate when you get to the finish
line celebrate all along the way some
way all along
away yeah man I know I put anything what
it takes to withstand the pressure slap
your neighbor and say you don't know
what you got you don't know what you've
got until all hell breaks loose you
don't know what you can take until the
pressure is applied to your life you
don't know what you can endure in people
until people stab you in the back and
walk away from you you don't know how
much courage you have until you've been
under fire and I'm their struggle and
I'm the tribulation you can't learn
what's in you sitting back in the lazy
boy chair in the remote control watching
HBO and Cinemax but when all hell breaks
loose
that's when you get to see
what you got touch that neighbor sound
made of something
I didn't get to see the design I didn't
get to see the architectural players but
I know I made us some good stuff I can
tell by the burdens up there and the
load I carry and the stuff I injure I
shot myself and what I'm able to take
it's not just that I sucked my enemies I
shot myself
they said I was gonna die and I believed
it but to hell and high water I'm still
yeah when I was in South Africa on a
safari I was blessed to be on a safari
after I had taught for a group of black
billionaires a seminar about faith in
finances and they detained me over and
gave me the privilege of staying out at
Jay Paul Gettys place out there in the
middle of the jungle somewhere and and
to go on a safari with my son it was
amazing so there I am in between a
zoologist school is giving me all of
this information about all the animals
their habitats or mating practices how
they live how they operate and sitting
on the edge of the Jeep with a shotgun
to protect us we weren't hunting we just
watch it was a Zulu Zulu says nothing at
all the zoologist explains all the
animals if we visited all the different
places and see a lot of animals but we
had not found the elephant he explained
the elephant but he could not find him
family there's a Zulu stood up and he
put his finger in there and he pointed
up he said the elephant is over there
but he said it to me my head exploded
Lyra
it exploded because all of us and I
realized I'm sitting between intellect
and instinct intellect can describe it
but only instinct can found it and from
the premise of that ideology I begin to
go back through all of my life and begin
to see not only me but others how if
they position themselves between
intellect and instinct and no claim to
yield to which one that next big thing
for there's an elephant an entrepreneur
pursuit or raising a family
it is simply over there if you follow
your instincts so many times you have a
modicum of talent in an area maybe just
enough talent to appreciate people
or really called to that area it doesn't
mean that you need to necessarily go out
and do that thing you must understand
that the purpose is an underlying of
chemistry that makes you live your life
it may not be you may not have a strong
time let me give an example Columbus
amount of let me give you an example I
have talented the musician I can play
the piano not well enough to be maestro
but I have a modicum of talent in that
area but that was not my purpose it but
many many times we start working in an
area that we have talent but it's not
our purpose I tell my kids this you may
start out doing something that is not
the thing you were created to do it may
only be the thing that leads to the
thing you were created to do you
understand what I'm saying actually so
you can don't stop at where you are as
if it were the destination when in fact
in reality it may be the transportation
that brings you into that thing you were
created to do you have to own your own
happiness take it away from other people
demanding that they make you happy your
kids are not going to make you happy
your spouse is not going to make you
happy a big house is not going to make
you happy on your own habit is to be
responsible for doing those things to
bring joy into your own heart
independently of life and people and
money and all of that stuff it doesn't
necessarily give you a happiness you
have to take responsibility of that
peace and that joy that lives inside of
your heart and not inside of your stuff
my challenge in our generation is it
gradually to entertainment through
television through media through every
way possible we are living in a
generation of the dumbing down of ideas
because we have traded effectiveness for
busyness statistics say yeah somebody
oughta clap a minute
we are busier than any other generation
we have seen in the last three to four
hundred years we are so busy we're we
are busier than a wall within a
one-armed wallpaper hanger richest B is
e because you'll get it later don't
worry about it at a hitch in a minute we
are just as busy as we can be and we
think because we're busy
we're effective but I want you to
challenge your schedule for a minute and
ask yourself are you are you really
being effective or is your life
cluttered with all kinds of stuff that
demands you and drains you and taxes you
and stops you from being your highest
and best self and are you substituting
busyness and all the chaos that goes
along with business from being effective
let me tell you a bunch of scientists
got together they begin to do some
research and they begin to determine
that 80% of the things we do are busy
things that we do in an area that is not
effective that the average person only
spends 20% of their time doing the thing
that they are really gifted and creative
and passionate about excited to do and
the rest of it is all the dismal dumb
stuff that we all have to do in order to
survive just crazy stuff that we're
doing wonder what would happen if we
would go from going 80% of things that
are busy but not effective and 20% of
the things that are really effective if
we would switch those numbers around and
only give 20% of our time to the things
that we have to do and 80% of our time
to the thing that we were created to do
wonder what would happen to your life
now think about it a minute I did a lot
of things you could take from me and I
could make it you could take my suit I
got another one you can take my car I
could get another one you can take my
house I could get another house but when
you take my time you have taken
something from me
that is totally irreplaceable we take
all kind of classes for money management
we know how to manage our money we know
how to repair our houses we're working
on our hair and our bodies and all this
kind of stuff we do everything except
the most important thing is to value our
time it takes time to be creative you
were meant to be creative you were
created in the likeness and the image of
a creator and in that likeness and in
that image you have creativity if you
had time you would be creative but in
the absence of time and with busyness
and clutter ve the following baby y'all
got music playing on your phone all
kinds of stuff and no matter what kind
of song you put on after why you hate to
hear it because every time you hear that
sound you know it's somebody else one
something else from you this taking you
away from what you are gifted and
creative to do the enemy does everything
he can to tear down your belief system
to destroy your belief system if you
open up a business if you open up a
company one of the things you have is
vision purpose and goals and you write
them down so all of your staff and all
your team and all your customers can
know this is who I am I am defined by my
Deason my purpose and my goals
that's my playbook that's my Creed
that's what I believe as a company as an
institution and never will forget
several years ago
Nike and if you ever get a chance to go
there toward Nike it's absolutely
amazing I could not find that employee
in all of lankey that wasn't quick to
tell me who they were they've ever
talked about who they work individually
they talked about who they were
corporately they knew their history they
knew they bet their background they knew
who they were as a company a philosophy
had so permeated the organization that
even the janitors would stop and tell
you the philosophy of Nike you see the
reason that's important if you know who
you are then you know who you are not if
you don't know who you are somebody can
ascribe any identity on to you and you
would morph into whatever they want you
to be and that's what has happened with
the whole lot of us some of us have been
ten or twelve different people depending
upon who we were with because we don't
know who we are we become whoever they
want us to be and then when they leave
us we are confused because we have no
real understanding of who we are you say
well I thought you were talking about
believing they god I'm talking about
believing God but I'm also talking about
believing in yourself Paul says I can do
all things through Christ which
strengthens me before he brings up
Christ he brings up him we saw amazing
he believed that God that we overlook
the fact that he believes in himself I
can do all things somebody said I can do
all the
oh my god just just I'm right there it
said again I can do all things wouldn't
it be amazing if you believe that when
you sleep good tonight if you believe
that wouldn't you walk around with your
head up at your back straight if you
believe that said again I can do all
things you would be intimidated by
anybody anywhere at any time if you just
believe that selling it I can do all
things can you imagine how different
your job interview would go if you
really believe that I won't did they say
what do you do I can do imagine if you
were taught that from the time you were
born into the world the first thing your
mama told you when they spike John the
behalf is don't worry about it baby you
can't do all things because people think
I often well that's for those people
over there or when I get when I get
myself together when I get myself
together I'm lonely of on purpose but
you say it is possible wherever you are
right now
Facebook anywhere in the world watching
us that even if you're in the middle of
a disaster right you can use that
disaster for direction absolutely I
because it is through the disaster it is
through the adversity that our strength
is developed if everything went the way
you wanted it to go you wouldn't have
anything to exercise my it's it's a
gymnasium of life where you get the
workout the resistance you find out
things about yourself that you didn't
know I'm stronger than I thought I was
I'm tougher than what I thought I was
I'm more resilient than I thought it was
and that self-respect stops you from
being at the mercy of other people to
validate you to make you feel good about
who you are what is something you
suggest to add to our daily routine to
empower ourselves quiet quiet
we're too busy we are so busy that we
don't notice that we're not productive
busy does not mean that you are
producing if we are just spinning our
wheels and the great thinking and
progress that we've made in this country
steam engines telephone
automobiles all types of thing of
spacecraft we're done by people who had
moments to think we're moving so fast at
breakneck speed and if we get a free
moment we're on Twitter and Facebook and
everything it's the death of creativity
and I would challenge people to go back
to meditation and and if your spiritual
go back to prayer if you're not just go
back to just laying still for a moment
to clear your head to hit the reset
button because we are starting every day
with the burdens from yesterday
assaulting us in today let's put a comma
between all of the I read somewhere is
an actor I think said it that once a
week
he doesn't talk mm-hmm if you don't talk
all day it just piece yeah yeah just
shut it all down and you'd be surprised
what you can hear when you shut up I
came to deliver a message to every
person in this room who's had a struggle
who's had some pains who's had some
tests who's got some creative ideas but
you've gone through some really tough
stuff let me tell you some of the stuff
you've been through don't pay it any
attention it is just a sign that the
baby is coming you're on the verge of
birthing you're on the verge of birthing
you're on the verge of perfect you're
about to give birth I want you to touch
everybody you can reach and tell them
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
you don't want to leave me now the baby
is coming you don't want to walk out on
me now the baby is coming I haven't had
my best idea yet I haven't had my most
creative moment yet
produce my dream yet I don't care
whether you're 30 40 50 60 70 there's
something bound inside of you they're
still kicking inside of you that wants
to get out and it wants to live it wants
to have the whole reason you're here
today is because there's something in
you that needs to be fed that needs to
be starred that needs to be electrified
that needs to be illuminated that
something
to this crowd
for you to give birth to the greatest
idea you have ever
she
who's going to miss it they're going to
miss it they're going to miss the
greatest part of you the greatest part
of your destiny the greatest part of
your creativity it took everything you
went through yesterday to get you ready
for what you are about to do today you
are standing on the verge of a Great
Awakening or you wouldn't be here if I'm
talking to you make some noise it is
can't hear you
I believe there are businesses in you
companies in you concepts in you books
to be written paintings to be drawn
concepts to be birth ideas creative
concepts there's something that you
could do that you could think in your
life that would radically change your
life somebody could take the hand you've
been dealt and win with it same
circumstances same ideas they would do
it through what they thought about your
life but we don't need somebody cuz we
got you we got you you're the one you
are the one I want you to join hands
with somebody for just a minute
I'm telling you right now if you are
going to birth your dream you're calling
your passion and the second half of your
life you can't draw back when life gets
tough you've got to stand up to it and
push get that person by the hand because
there's something inside of them that is
about to happen squeeze their hand
and when I count to three I want every
man and every woman that's got a concept
that's got an idea
I want you to push with all of your
might until dreams and concepts and
ideas start to birth out of you in the
middle of the night
you will need pens and pads by your bed
tonight because you're going to get up
in the middle of the night and start
writing down all the stuff that's going
to start coming out of your spirit are
you ready
rushon
from a tack
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Christopher
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of the top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you leave it in the
comments I'll join in discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon
if you're looking for me I'm not up
there I'm up here you may be seated
if you're looking for a leadership you
don't always have to look to the front
to find it
you
great leadership doesn't start out on
the stage
it doesn't start out as governor's or
mayor's or presidents or CEOs or
managers great leadership starts out in
the back leadership starts in the pews
if you're in a church it starts in the
pews if you're in the business it starts
down in the janitorial booths it starts
with menial things that's why the Bible
said verse 5 is not the day of small
beginnings you have to understand though
and I want you to get this in your mind
and in your heart and most of all in
your head about leadership when you
begin to grapple with leadership and
life begins to move your long career
opportunities or other leads the
presence of the Holy Spirit begins to
move you along because promotion really
doesn't come from the East of the West
it really does come from God it is
possible for life to lead you faster
then your mind is prepared to handle God
can move you into such a place it
positionally you are in a state of
leadership but mentally and emotionally
you really haven't got a grip on what
life has handed you and if you don't
know what you have you don't know how to
take care of it if you don't know how to
take care of it you can mess around and
lose it the truth of the matter is a
leaders come from ordinary places they
deal with ordinary issues and I'm going
to share some things with you that I
think are very very helpful for you to
realize first of all I want you to
understand that when you're saying to
yourself that you want to be a great
leader and you want to really go the
extra mile and you want to do what has
to be done you're asking for trouble
you are absolutely asking for trouble
you're asking for trouble and if you
think about this event it you'll learn a
very important concept that I think you
need to understand in the corporate
world in the business world they
actually pay you more money as you move
up the ladder with more responsibilities
okay so if you are a superintendent you
might not make as much of the general
manager a general manager might not make
as much as a regional manager a CEO
would make more than a regional manager
let me tell you something they're paying
you for conflict it's are you hearing
what I'm saying
it's it's not enough to have the degrees
what they're paying you for is your
ability to manage conflict and pressure
and struggles you have to fix the mine
before you can bestow the blessing
because until they give their mind right
everything you invest in them is going
to leak out of the crevices of a mind
that refuses to change look at your
neighbor and ask them do you have a mind
to change
wait for an answer
if they said no drag them to the altar
tell them they got your midnight to get
that fixed
they've got to midnight to dump out all
jealousy all pettiness all unforgiveness
all strife all malice all confusion all
blaming other people for your mistake
you got till midnight to get rid of
every poison that's hindering you every
inflexibility that's stopping you from
what God is about to pour into your life
won't be unto you if you go into another
year and waste another year with the old
mentality while somebody's in the
hospital begging God for the opportunity
that you have right now you better step
into this moment
lay your hands on your head and say give
me a new mind
give me a new mind means give me a new
perspective give me a new perspective
give me a new way of looking at my
situation give me a new way of looking
at my circumstances get my mind ready
for this year because when I get this
year there's going to be blessings
there's going to be miracles there's
going to be opportunities oh yes there's
going to be some struggles it's going to
be some challenges it's going to be some
tests but even the struggles are an
opportunity for me to show off the
victory if my mind can handle the change
you got what it takes
storms come winds blow lightning flashes
things aren't fair things are sitting
there nerve-wracking but the very fact
that he allowed it to happen
seeing as he is architect it is a sign
that he's looked at the specs he knows
what he put in you he knows his grace is
sufficient to get you to this moment
and salanio are about to feel like
threesome now somebody in this room
knows you've been through some stuff
that if anybody would have told you that
you had to deal with that you would have
said hey no way I can handle it
but every time you got ready to give up
there was something on the inside they
kept telling you go ahead go ahead
if you're ready here to play slap your
neighbor and say I'm still here
I've been tried but I'm still here
I've been battered but I'm still here
I've been lonely
what I'm still here I've been frustrated
but I'm still here I cried when I'm
still here
somebody help me break
halleluyah halleluyah
I'm your neighbor and say you've got
what it takes you won't make it out of
this storm you will survive this attack
you
this stage in your life you have got
hello down
don't know who I'm preaching to but a
long preaching to somebody the devil in
telling you you had your breaking point
but the devil is love to architect you
don't know what God put in Sally
now better
Oh